the Joe Rogan experience I was just
telling the story of when you sent Ben
and I to the sensory deprivation tank
the flow tank in Venice and with crash
crash my man yeah and I kind of went in
and crash was basically like look I'm
gonna lock the doors and you guys are
like in here you know do your thing and
so I was in the tank and I got to this
point where I like started to panic and
I thought I was just trying to sort of
go somewhere and then I was like what
what a crash didn't we've opened the air
vent and I'm gonna suffocate go for the
door and then I got it in my eye
[Laughter]
maybe I'm not sure and I ended up like
going I had to like jump out and go to
the shower and I was like my eyes all
rinsed out and I kind of sat there in a
towel like it's so ridiculous
I failed my first float thing you never
get these vents there's air I went to a
cryotherapy in Austin one of the last
times I was there and I loved it
it's great right awesome I got I didn't
last the three minutes I did like 2:30
before I started to panic I think
they're supposed to make you do - the
first time I did 2:30 that's your rebel
[Music]
[Laughter]
who was the first woman to say suck my
dick was it I was gonna say I hope I
would hope it's like remember she was a
Navy SEAL she's like suck my dick
[Laughter]
that was the best a woman who's ever
said suck my dick now you're the queen
wow that is a great honor sir I believe
and I you know I did have a nickname and
it was suck my dick Seuss say a little
too often it's like a reflex but it's a
cool thing that a girl could tape though
she's never dick and everything's
hilarious like no one gets offended
rageous like you're off the team
yeah woman like you think suck one day
and this is where I get the me too from
you guys like a good indicator of like
like the douche baggage nurse she was
upset of you saying suck my dick who are
you
yeah well that's the climate we're in
which is kind of scary
I don't think that way though it's not
that way because that would require men
to be upset at a woman for saying
something like suck my dick that he
hasn't gotten that crazy yet I hope now
the only way it could ever is
immortality I don't think so either
there's a lot of [ __ ] amongst us
there's a lot of [ __ ] amongst us it
could go bad we can hit the rocks and
then bounce back you know what we need
but we need to conquer those inner
[ __ ] they're just not capable getting
up
they can't yeah there's gonna be no
movement agreed boom they're gonna hit
that wall there's some guys look there's
a for sure a lot of men who would try to
claim that way in that direction well
let's hope that's not the case with this
podcast
[Laughter]
creating a penis was a [ __ ]
horrendous injustice you appropriated
pretty sure I said that at one of my
poker games
I'm pretty sure I said that at one of
the last poker games I played and nobody
laughed so I was like oh oh you're
[ __ ] playing poker with a bunch of
serious normies buncha normies that
can't handle it
[Applause]